[Music]
let's go to Fort Collins Colorado and
talk to Kate what's up
Kate Hi how are you I I'm great I'm my
I'm a lot sorry I probably came on a
little bit strong there how are
you I'm good a little under the weather
so bear with my rough voice you sounded
like you're a couple margaritas into the
morning so that's good I wish
I wish what's
up so I emailed you last week asking how
I can get my mom to stop sending us
crappy
gifts I'm not I'm I'm laughing at you
and with you both okay tell me about
this what kind of crappy gift it is kind
of funny but it's been going on my whole
life John
um so she will randomly send you know
things that are wrapped these are gifts
this is like a Christmas or a
birthday um I think I even mentioned I
one time got a used bar of soap we have
the same monogram so um you know belts
that she pulled out out of her husband's
closet for my ex-husband um just really
random stuff and it has always sent the
message to me that I'm not
worth while I'm not worth her time her
effort her money and it's crazy how much
of a pervasive problem this has been our
relationship I had to cut her out of my
life for a few years and um recently
brought her back in and I let her come
to our house I've got four kids and she
wanted to come watch my son play
football and I was like all right we
need to do some maintenance beforehand
and we work through some things I've
been in
therapy part of her visitation I was
like please do not bring anything with
you she's like I've got some old pants
I've outgrown I'm like no no you know
thank you you I'll I'll look at him when
I come to to visit you well she still
proceeded to bring all kinds of stuff
she left and then she started mailing
things to me and John it it just sent me
over the edge I was so so angry when she
sent this last package it was like
broken jewelry and you know stuff I
would never wear and I have I've asked
her I've said if you insist on getting
us gifts just get us gift cards or just
don't give us anything at all and you
know I don't want to come across as
ungrateful but truly I'd rather just not
have anything I just don't know how to
handle
it so like in my mind I I instantly go
to what seems like a parallel that I
know is not but I it seems like a
parallel which is like junk mail we're
going to be in your area doing gutters
and we'd love to do your gutters for 10%
Like and that stuff never even enters my
house it just goes straight from my
mailbox into the trash can into the
recycle bin whatever so there has to be
something deeper you mentioned earlier
you created a story around these
gifts that this that the story you
created for yourself around these gifts
is my mom thinks so little of
me that this is what she thinks I'm
worth where does that story come from
well she's that's 100% true well how you
know I go ahead I'm sorry well what's
the other side of and I always try to
think up an alternative story that that
might counter what I my the pervasive
story I have in my head is and what if
she stole her husband's favorite belt
because he loved it so much and was like
I'm gonna give this to her husband like
is there a chance that she loves this
stuff so much or she just is she have
mental health diagnos diagnosis like
what's this it sounds pathological she
can't
stop I know um yeah I mean the reason
that I gave our relationship almost a
5year break was it was my birthday and
she gave me this necklace and as she you
know if she had not said anything I
probably wouldn't have received it the
way that I did but she was like it's I
know you don't like blue and I know you
don't like silver but it was really
expensive and and it wasn't I took it
back and was able to exchange it for a
tube of
mascara um you know I I don't know what
it is I don't know if she's just like I
have to show up with something so I've
gotta you know do this but you know I've
I've been my therapist said maybe you
could just ship it back to her which
requires you know work on my part yeah I
don't want to do chores for something
but I but but here's the like I got a
buddy and he believes it is wholly
inhospitable to show up to an invitation
to somebody's house even if it's just
like hey come on over we're fill in the
blank we're watching the game or come on
over he cannot like psychologically
enter into somebody's home without a
welcome gift of some sort and he has
shown up to my house with like ends of
mosquite wood like in a bag that go in a
grill and it would never occur to me to
bring so I I but I always look past it
to this is his small wife saying um
thanks for having me
over and I guess in my head there's no
skin off of it but I haven't created a
story around it so I guess the question
I would ask you is what's more important
your relationship with your mom or the
story cuz the the things that she's
given you are
benign unless it is her subtly and with
a great amount of like claw digging like
just taking a dig this is her way of
flipping you off and being able to go
what
what that's how it feels but I is that
how it I'm trying to a that she loves me
and that you know because I would never
engage in that behavior with my own
children of course and yeah and so let's
let's road test
it like imagine you've written that on a
note card my mom sends me gifts in the
form like broken jewelry and whatever
dolls with missing eyeballs and she
gives me gifts that she says out loud I
know you're not going to like this but
wow I spent a bunch of money on it put
that on a note card an imaginary note
card and hold it as far away as you can
like put your arm way out there and road
test it read that is that story
true is it true I don't care how it
feels I guess is that story
true yeah it is
okay then you've answered your question
and I think the Humane thing to do is
the the the way that you don't lose your
humanity is you continue to treat
somebody with dignity or respect even if
they don't offer you the same I'm a big
believer in this I think it would heal a
lot of our world but you tell her with
with all dignity and respect hey I've
asked you multiple times since we're
back together we're back in each other's
lives to not bring gifts and you seem
unable to not do
that I'm going to have to for my sake
for my kids sake I'm going to have to um
put up some pretty significant
boundaries let that be that if you ghost
here I think that's
cruel and if you if you mail it back
that just feels Petty to me I don't want
to badmouth your accounts I just feels
like I'll show you like yeah like that
just feels like I'm not going to solm
anything I think you're right back throw
it in the trash I mean you can you're
still in the
trash I'd always have that fear that she
dropped a diamond ring in there or
something but I mean believe me we think
that every time every time everyone's
hopes gets up and we're 100% always
disappointed so but I like where you're
saying just like test it if it's true
and then the boundary is no more yeah if
it's true it's true I often I'm trying
to think of something I'll I'll I've
used this this example before but my
wife and I will have a conversation
about hey you're like wet towels on the
floor and like can you please that like
makes me crazy I don't know why it just
does and then I walk in the next day and
that wet towels on the floor and
instantly I create a story about oh dude
she is flipping me off she knows I I was
vulnerable I told her it's a big deal to
me and she just dropped it here on
purpose I can make that story
up and then when I think of that story
in context with the extraordinary woman
that I married who spends most of her
life making sure that I know I'm loved
and that my life runs like in any shape
form or
fashion then I can make up another story
which is my God what had to happen
today right after we just talked about
this that there's another towel
here this house must have got off the
rails my kids must have been trying to
set things on fire and bury the dog in
the yard and barbecue like the neighbors
like pet like what it must have been so
bananas here and I pick up the towel and
I go on about my day see what I'm saying
so if you look at that and go no no no
this was on purpose she's just trying to
she's trying to rub salt in a pretty
deep
wound cool you've got your answer and
it's hard and it's heartbreaking you'll
have to grieve the fact that your mom
would rather flip you off than honor you
and your kids I can't think of a thing
that would be worse than
that yeah it's hard and that's where
I've struggled with just it's not really
about the gifts John oh I know it's not
she spits on your boundaries bad when
I'm around her yeah yeah she spits on
your boundaries and my guess is this
isn't the only thing she violates oh
dear no no so I think what you need to
make peace with is entering into a
season of
grief cuz either your mom is like wholly
unwell and unwilling to go get well
well or your mom enjoys watching you
squirm
yeah okay and I hate that for you I wish
that wasn't the case I don't think
anybody should have to deal with that
with their
mom same yeah all
right yeah I hate it for you but I think
it's right if you can hold that in an
imaginary note card or if you're a
gangster right in a real note card hold
it out in front of you
is this
true did that guy really cut me off in
traffic because he's just doing drugs
and wants to see us all die
or did he cut me off in traffic because
he's trying his best to get to the
hospital before his wife dies I get to
pick whichever one of those stories but
if you know one to be true if he flips
you off all the way over and he's
eyeballing you and he cuts you off you
know that that story is
true if your mom keeps doing it Mom do
not send stuff okay okay she shows up
with a bunch of stuff and goes I know
you won't even like this one
yeah unfortunately it sounds like Mom
may be opting out of your relationship
I'm
sorry especially especially after you
tried let her back in right here during
the holiday
season spend some time in grief and
please please please continue to honor
your mother not by letting her run all
over your family and hurt you and your
kids honor your mom by being honest
telling her the truth and putting up
very very firm boundaries that are gonna
hold and then maybe you sit down up
against one of those boundaries and just
weep because it's not supposed to be
this
way